Your book is phenomenal. I enjoyed it immensely. I've been a fan of SNL,
uh, since I can remember. So let's start with a title, a very punchable face.
Uh, you know, I think most people like find that funny, uh,
and there's like a theme of self-deprecation throughout the book. Um,
so what were the, what was the process behind your deciding on a title?
Because I know the title of your first book is actually kind of a big decision.
It is, it's like with music, you put out an album, you,
the first one can just be your name, you know, it's easy. No, you know,
that's just like the industry standard, you got an eponymous album, but that's,
you know, with books, you got to actually think about it, you know? Um, I wanna,
I also, before I start wanting to thank you, um, I was,
I'm very honored that you,
that you agreed to do this and talk to me and I'm a big fan of yours.
And I think what you brought to the campaign was such an elevated
and fresh set of ideas,
and you were just really fun to watch.
And also you, you, you like,
it was the only new ideas that were out there. And I really, uh, I,
I don't know, I gained like a whole new, uh,
like idea of what a candidate could be from watching you.
And I hope that your ideas continue and that you continue and,
and make them a reality cause it was really inspiring to see. So thank you.
And thank you for doing this cause it means a lot. Um, I, uh, I,
I, I wrote about a lot of,
so there's a lot of self-deprecating and humiliating things in my book.
I really wanted it always my book to be entertaining. Um,
I didn't want it to be, uh,
trying to be overly educational or pedantic in any way,
or I didn't want it to be, um,
just taking weird victory laps about anything or, or just like name,
dropping stuff. I wanted it to be stories that I thought were, were,
you know, that were funny and that people would, would like reading and,
and I ran everything through that filter and it turns out a lot of those stories
ended up being ones where I was injured, um,
or humiliated or emotionally abused or,
um, uh, you know, just by my own dumb decisions, uh,
got injured or put in a terrible position. And I thought, you know,
that would be entertaining. And it seems like people do enjoy when I, when,
when, uh, you know, injurious things happened to me.
I, I confess that after reading your book,
like you did start to resemble one of those action movie heroes in my mind where
like you take your shirt off and then there's like this scarf of that.
This is from like the Google mishap. This is from the bike.
This is from the surfing.
So you started to resemble that kind of figure in my
mind. Uh.
Wow.
You're also, as, as we all know, you're engaged to, uh,
like a superhero that, you know, everyone's growing, growing up with.
So there's that too. That's another reason why you seem like an action hero.
No real superhero, but also that's not she's, it is a movie.
So I confessed to being, and this is one thing I liked about your book too,
is that like your, you know, your book was very, very personal. Um,
but like you said, it wasn't like a name-dropping type book.
It was like personal about your childhood,
personal about your formative experiences, which were very funny,
like consistently. Um, I, you know,
I feel like I understand Staten Island better, thanks to your book.
And also I happened to have seen, um, King of Staten Island, uh, you know,
relatively recently. And so like between that and your book, like,
I feel like I understand the fifth borough, uh,
hopefully it's not an insult be called with it, bro.
And that's one of the nicest things anyone's ever said about that Island.
Staten Island. We're part of New York. It's real,
we swear. Uh, and,
and so you went from Staten Island, you went to high school in the city,
which also had many, many funny, um, anecdotes, certainly the most effecting,
very, very quintessentially New York story,
I thought was the story of your mom and her bravery, uh, during nine 11. Uh,
and I was in New York, um, on that day,
like I remember when the towers fell was a beautiful day in terms of the
weather, like, you know, not a cloud in the sky.
And then you hear that a plane crash in the world trade center. Uh,
and I was part of the crowd of thousands that just started
walking away from downtown. Like I was near the empire state building. Uh,
I showed up to work and then this happens and then everyone in the office is
like, we should get the heck outta here. Um, and then we start walking North.
Um, but your mom did the opposite. Your mom actually headed towards the towers,
which to me is probably the most heroic thing I can imagine doing,
having been on the Island that day.
Like every human instinct is like go away from, uh, uh,
from what is happening. And she actually went, went towards it.
Yeah. I mean, um, it's, I don't,
I don't know how that, that instincts happens. I think she, she,
you probably don't know until that moment happens,
how you're going to handle it.
And I think it probably for her came from knowing that all her,
you know, all the firefighters that she knew and worked with and,
and loved were all in there were, were,
were closer or near the buildings. And,
and I think she genuinely wanted to help them, um, and,
and help get them out of that situation or help treat them. Um, you know,
I don't think she,
I don't think she ever imagined that the,
that the buildings would both fall, you know, I think that she didn't, you know,
she knew they had been hit and she kind of gradually figured out once,
depending on and been hit that it was a,
that there was a clearly a coordinated terrorist act,
but I don't think she ever thought structurally something like that would
happen. I mean, it was so crazy to start seeing happening because you don't,
even when things get hit, you know, you just don't expect that to happen.
So maybe she, uh, you know, I don't know that she ever thought that,
that I don't think she could imagine that that would have happened. Yeah.
Well, that chapter certainly humanized you and your family, uh,
in an incredible way because frankly, people look at you and think, Oh,
I sit now famous celebrity engaged to a celebrity. And then when you,
when you read about your mom rushing towards the towers, uh,
the fact that her life was saved twice by firemen who were right there with
her, that the people she was with, um, lost their lives, uh, that, that day.
And then you imagine, uh, you know, you, and obviously like, you know,
people associate this with, uh, with your cast mates, Pete Davidson as well.
Like you realize that like the human condition, uh,
like it's, uh, it's your family,
it's Pete's family, it's the 343 families that got, um, uh,
that got devastated that day, who were families of firefighters.
And it seems like your family has so,
so much of like the firefighter DNA, uh, like in your,
uh, like your family's history. Like, I, I felt like I got to know you better,
uh, as a result of sharing in that experience.
It was, you know, it's such a, it's the community I knew the most, and it was,
you know, like my, you know, my grandfather was a fireman.
My great grandfather was a fireman, all my cousins and, um, my uncles,
everyone who lives on my block,
where my whole family lives mostly on Staten Island,
we're all in the fire department.
So I knew it forever as this really fun community of, of all these,
like, I feel like firefighters are some of the funniest people and, and really,
uh, a loving group of people. And then after that, there was a whole other,
you know, obviously element to it and you, and it was even more of a community,
but in a whole different kind of way. Um, and I thought that one of the most,
uh, the things that my mom said that was the craziest to me was, you know,
when I went, I went, I remember going to visit, uh,
the head fire department headquarters where they have, they keep wa uh, uh,
basically a wall of the names of all the firefighters who died in the line of
duty.
And she said that in the first hundred years of the department,
they filled one wall. And then that day on September 11th,
they filled an entire other wall. Like that was, that was what the,
the sheer numbers for the department were. And, and, and, and Staten Island,
obviously,
including Pete's dad was part of that wall and a substantial part of that
wall on Staten Island. So, um, you know, I, I'm,
I'm very proud of my mom and that's why I wanted to write that chapter. And, uh,
I really feel.
For her of, of going through that and losing colleagues like that,
you know, people, I was surprised by so much of your background because,
you know, I think they'll have very high level view is, um, you went,
went to Harvard, uh, that's one thing, and you had like a really fun, uh,
set of stories about Harvard. Uh, and so you don't think, Oh, you know,
like the mother works for the fire department, uh, you know,
grandfather was a fireman, uh, you think like, Oh, he went to Harvard. So,
you know,
maybe his parents were like orthodontists or whatever his
parents were president and vice-president of Harvard
or something or something. Right. Like the wiggle bot.
And then when you went to Harvard too,
like you framed it in such human terms where like, there's like this Haba,
like mystique, and then like you unpacked it, um, in such a humble way.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know,
every time we have a new episode.